(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos aprender quem pode participar
dos leilões de imóveis.
Via de regra, qualquer pessoa maior de idade,
capaz e na livre administração dos seus bens,
pode participar de um leilão de imóvel.
Ou seja, aquela pessoa que não está impedida
poderá participar normalmente.
Pessoa jurídica também pode participar de um leilão
normalmente.
Basta que ela seja representada por quem tem
poderes para agir em nome da empresa, para
adquirir imóveis em nome daquela empresa.
Existem restrições muito específicas de pessoas que não
podem participar de leilão.
Vamos estudar aqui quais são essas restrições.
Primeiro, tutores, curadores, testamenteiros, mandatários e administradores dos
bens que estão em sua guarda.
Essas pessoas só não podem participar de um
leilão de um bem que ela mesmo esteja
administrando, que esteja sobre sua guarda.
Por que a lei colocou essa disposição?
Para que essas pessoas não pudessem agir de
má fé, administrando os bens de má fé
e depois se beneficiar desse imóvel indo a
leilão com desconto.
Então a lei proíbe que essas pessoas participem
dos leilões que estão sobre sua guarda.
Mas aqui uma ressalva.
Caso você seja tutor, curador, testamenteiro, mandatário de
alguém, você só não pode participar desses bens
específicos.
De qualquer outro leilão, de qualquer outro imóvel,
você vai poder participar normalmente.
Segunda exceção.
Os leiloeiros e os seus prepostos não podem
participar dos bens que estejam sobre sua guarda.
O preposto do leiloeiro é toda aquela pessoa
que pode agir em nome do leiloeiro, que
representa o leiloeiro.
Então esses são excluídos exatamente para que o
leilão tenha o máximo de concorrência possível.
Porque é vantajoso tanto para o poder judiciário,
tanto quanto para o proprietário daquele imóvel, ou
seja, o devedor, tanto para o credor, que
quanto maior o lance arrecadado no leilão, melhor.
Então, excluir o leiloeiro e os prepostos da
possibilidade de arrematar algum bem que esteja sobre
sua responsabilidade para ser levado ao leilão, é
colocar aquele bem em concorrência.
É um estímulo para que o leiloeiro dê
o máximo de publicidade possível para aquele leilão
que vai acontecer, porque assim ele vai ganhar
sua comissão sobre um lance maior do que
um leilão que não teria nenhuma publicidade.
Terceira exceção.
Servidores da Justiça, membros do Ministério Público, Defensoria
Pública, dos bens que estão sendo leiloados na
localidade em que servirem ou exercerem autoridade.
Qual é o entendimento aqui aplicado pelo STJ
sobre os servidores da Justiça?
O entendimento é que esses servidores só não
poderão participar dos leilões ordenados diretamente pelo juízo
ao qual estão vinculados.
De todos os demais leilões, esses servidores poderão
participar normalmente.
Qual é a finalidade dessa restrição?
A finalidade é impedir que um servidor da
Justiça possa se beneficiar de alguma autoridade que
ele exerce sobre aquele determinado leilão e assim
arrematar aquele bem pagando um valor abaixo do
que normalmente seria conseguido em um leilão.
Então, se você for um servidor da Justiça,
fique atento que você só não pode participar
diretamente do juízo que você está vinculado.
De todos os demais você pode.
Existe uma exceção a essa regra.
Essa exceção diz respeito aos juízes.
Os juízes não podem participar de nenhum leilão
ordenado pelo tribunal no qual atua.
E não só daqueles bens que ele mesmo
manda leilão.
O juiz está proibido de participar de qualquer
leilão do tribunal no qual atua, mas ainda
assim ele vai poder participar de leilões realizados
por outros tribunais.
Porque nos outros tribunais ele não exerce qualquer
autoridade e vai poder competir normalmente com qualquer
outra pessoa.
Quarta exceção.
Servidores públicos em geral quanto aos bens ou
direitos da pessoa jurídica a que servirem ou
que estejam sob sua administração direta ou indireta.
Então, se você for um servidor público da
União, por exemplo, você não pode participar de
nenhum leilão em que esteja diretamente vinculada a
União.
Mas de todos os outros leilões você poderá
participar.
A mesma coisa se você for um servidor
estadual.
Você não poderá participar de nenhum leilão em
que esteja envolvido o Estado que te remunera.
Mas de todos os outros leilões você poderá
participar normalmente.
Quinta exceção.
Advogados das partes envolvidas naquele leilão.
Os advogados das partes são proibidos de participar
daquele leilão.
Entra com o mesmo fundamento daquela primeira exceção
que a gente estudou dos tutores, curadores, mandatários.
O advogado não pode participar exatamente para que
não seja um estímulo que um advogado agisse
de má fé em algum processo, deixando de
exercer a defesa correta de seu cliente para
depois se beneficiar de um imóvel que seu
cliente vai perder por um preço muito mais
barato em algum leilão.
Então os advogados somente das partes envolvidas naquele
leilão são detados de participar daquele leilão.
De todos os demais leilões os advogados podem
participar normalmente.
Então perceba nessas exceções que são exceções muito
rescritas a determinados casos.
E nesses casos a pessoa terá uma restrição
também pequena para participar, já que ela não
poderá participar de um caso específico, mas poderá
participar de todos os demais leilões que existam.
Para os leilões da Caixa Econômica, a Caixa
coloca também algumas restrições quanto aos seus funcionários.
Então se você for um funcionário da Caixa,
fique atento se você se enquadra em alguma
dessas exceções.
Se você não for um funcionário da Caixa,
você poderá normalmente participar dos leilões feitos pela
Caixa Econômica.
Para os funcionários, quais são as exceções?
Empregados vinculados à Superintendência Nacional de Infraestrutura e
Patrimônio, e os empregados vinculados à Superintendência Nacional
de Rede Negocial e Executiva Habitação.
E os dirigentes da Caixa hierarquicamente superiores a
essas duas áreas que a gente mencionou acima,
bem como os seus cônjuges ou companheiros.
Então é uma restrição que atinge o funcionário
especificamente, e o cônjuge e o companheiro daquele
funcionário, para que ninguém possa se beneficiar de
uma informação às vezes privilegiada que esse funcionário
de alto grau da Caixa possa ter.
Para todos os demais funcionários da Caixa, acesso
livre.
Para quem não é funcionário da Caixa, também
igualmente acesso livre a todos os leilões realizados
pela Caixa Econômica.
Existem formas também de fazer uma arrematação em
conjunto, tanto como pessoa física, quanto como uma
pessoa jurídica.
Se esse for seu caso, se você quiser
participar de um leilão com várias pessoas pagando
uma parte daquela arrematação, saiba que isso é
possível.
Quando você realiza um cadastro como pessoa física
no site do Leiloeiro, você vai se deparar
com somente um campo para preenchimento do CPF,
um campo para preenchimento de um nome, e
um campo para preenchimento dos demais dados pessoais.
Então não é possível que você faça um
login contendo vários CPFs.
O login necessariamente vai estar vinculado a um
único CPF.
Mas você pode oferecer lance em conjunto com
outras pessoas.
Como?
Uma pessoa vai oferecer o lance e depois
essa pessoa que ofereceu o lance vai entrar
em contato com o Leiloeiro para falar que
o valor daquela arrematação não vai ser pago
somente por ele, que o valor daquela arrematação
vai ser pago por duas ou mais pessoas.
E vai pedir para que o Leiloeiro coloque
na documentação do leilão, em primeiro lugar é
feito o alço de arrematação, os dados de
todas as pessoas que vão pagar por aquele
lance e a respectiva fração que cada uma
daquelas pessoas vai ter sobre aquele imóvel.
Então vamos supor que você vai arrematar um
imóvel com mais três pessoas, totalizando quatro.
Vocês fizeram uma divisão igual, todos vão pagar
o mesmo valor e todos vão ter 25
% daquele imóvel.
Uma daquelas pessoas vai realizar o lance em
seu login.
Após o leilão ser encerrado, essa pessoa que
realizou o lance deve entrar em contato com
o Leiloeiro para informar que, além dele, tem
mais três pessoas que vão participar daquele pagamento
e essas três pessoas também devem ser inseridas
na documentação do leilão, cada uma ficando com
25% daquele imóvel.
É perfeitamente possível.
Antes de você entrar num leilão desse tipo,
entre em contato com o Leiloeiro, porque existem
leiloeiros que pedem para que as quatro pessoas
se habilitem naquele leilão, apesar de somente uma
oferecer o lance.
O que o leiloeiro pode pedir isso?
Para que ele já tenha previamente a documentação
de todo mundo ali em seu sistema, que
ele já tenha conferido aquela documentação e tenha
dado ok para todo mundo.
Existem leiloeiros que não pedem isso, que ele
pede somente que o arrematante, após o leilão,
entre em contato e passe os demais dados.
Então, se esse for seu caso, se você
quiser fazer essa arrematação em conjunto, liga para
o leiloeiro e pergunte se vai ser necessário
todo mundo se habilitar ou se somente após
o leilão basta que você forneça os dados
de todo mundo.
Existe outra forma também de fazer essa arrematação
em conjunto que seria uma forma um pouco
mais complexa, que seria constituindo uma pessoa jurídica
no nome de todos os interessados em participar
daquele leilão.
Isso aqui só é recomendado realmente se você
for fazer arrematações em série, em conjunto com
outras pessoas e se essas pessoas forem sempre
as mesmas pessoas, porque se não faz sentido
você abrir uma empresa para fazer uma única
arrematação, depois mudar aquele grupo de pessoas que
você vai arrematar, depois você abrir outra empresa,
isso não faz sentido nenhum.
Abrir empresa tem custo, isso seria onerar você
de uma forma desnecessária.
Mas, se você quiser juntar um grupo de
pessoas para sempre realizar arrematações, talvez seja mais
interessante constituir uma pessoa jurídica, que isso aí
vai dar segurança para todo mundo e vai
evitar que toda vez tenha que ser feito
esse procedimento com o leiloeiro.
A pessoa jurídica vai arrematar no nome dela
e no contrato social daquela pessoa jurídica já
vai ter a qualificação de todos os sócios
daquela empresa, definindo a porcentagem de lucro que
cada um terá naquele negócio.
Nesse momento eu sei que você está se
perguntando qual é a melhor tributação para arrematar
um imóvel.
Se é melhor arrematar um imóvel para fins
tributários, em pessoa física ou em pessoa jurídica.
Eu vou pedir para você segurar essa sua
dúvida, porque a gente vai ter uma aula
específica no módulo 4 sobre esse tema.
Se é melhor arrematar em pessoa física ou
melhor arrematar em pessoa jurídica.
O objetivo dessa aula era tão somente expor
quem pode participar de um leilão e também
expor essa forma de arrematação em conjunto.